Emmanuel est un ami très proche je suis
très fier d'avoir été à l'origine de de
sa carrière et c'est un homme très
intéressant et je suis convaincu qu'il
sera un jour président de la
République je suis convaincu qu'il le
sera un jour s' s'il a la persistance de
de de d'accepter les défaites
d'apprendre je suis convaincu qu'il le
sera un jour vous lui demandez d'être
patient je demande pas je je lui dis je
le sais d'ailleurs parce que nous en
avons souvent parlé je pense que que il
espère être président cette fois-ci mais
je pense P qu'il construit une vraie
carrière et que c'est très courageux de
sa part d'avoir alors qu'il aurait pu
faire tout à fait autre chose d'avoir
accepté de participer à la vie
démocratique